Pyrrhon d'Élis partait parfois en voyage
sans prévenir personne. Un jour, son navire
fut pris dans une tempête. Celle-ci durait,
au point qu’elle plongea les membres de
l’équipage dans la dépression. Le philosophe
leur montra alors un petit cochon qui mangeait
avec une grande imperturbabilité malgré
le danger. La bête d’ordinaire méprisée
était donc, dans ces circonstances exceptionnelles,
un modèle d’ataraxie pour l’homme. Cette
anecdote nous invite à réfléchir à la
manière dont l’être humain se rapporte
à l’animal.
L’homme est l’être vivant appartenant
à l’espèce Homo sapiens. Il est principalement
caractérisé par 1° la station verticale,
2° la multifonctionnalité de la main, 3°
le développement considérable du cerveau,
et 4° la communication par le langage articulé.
Un animal est un être vivant qui se distingue
des êtres végétaux par 1° la mobilité,
2° la sensibilité, 3° la représentation,
et 4° l’incapacité de se nourrir directement
d’éléments inorganiques.
La distinction des deux termes est importante
pour l’être humain, car il ne semble pas
vouloir qu’on le confonde avec l’animal.
Il est plutôt rare que l’homme voie en
une bête un modèle positif. Au contraire,
les animaux sont souvent sa « boussole sud
» : ce que fait l’animal, c’est ce qu’il
ne faut pas faire. Sa saleté, son ignorance,
et son impulsivité sont indignes d’un être
humain. Ne dit-on pas, pour la blâmer, d’une
personne stupide, grossière, ou brutale qu’elle
est « un animal » ? Ne se sert-on pas du
même mot — « bête » — en tant que
nom commun, pour désigner l’animal, et
en tant qu’adjectif, pour qualifier un homme
qui manque d’intelligence ? Une pléthore
d’indices laissent à penser que l’être
humain se voit lui-même avant tout comme
n’étant pas un animal. Pourquoi donc paraît-il
tant tenir à la distinction ? Il ne faut
néanmoins pas s’arrêter à ce constat,
ainsi que le suggère Pyrrhon d'Élis lorsqu’il
invite à s’inspirer de la tranquillité
d’un petit cochon. La différence avec l’animal
est-elle véritablement aussi radicale que
l’homme ne le pense ? Si tel n’était
pas le cas, alors cela signifierait qu’il
y aurait en réalité de l’animal en l’homme.
Comment dès lors comprendre le rapport de
l’humanité à l’animalité ?
Dans quelle mesure l’homme diffère-t-il
vraiment de l’animal ?
Si l’homme semble se définir lui-même
comme un être vivant radicalement supérieur
à l’animal (I), il ne peut cependant pas
nier la part d’animalité qui le caractérise
(II), mais c’est en dépassant l’animal
qui est en lui que l’être humain accomplirait
son humanité (III).
L’homme tient à la distinction de l’humanité
et de l’animalité parce qu’il se situe
lui-même au sommet de la hiérarchie du vivant.
Force est de constater, tout d’abord, que
l’être humain a acquis une position dominante
par rapport aux animaux. Qu’ils soient sauvages,
destinés à l’élevage, ou domestiques,
ils sont à la merci de l’homme. Cela n’a
certes pas toujours été le cas. Les humains
sont restés de faibles créatures craintives
pendant 2 millions d’années. Ils ont commencé
à affronter les prédateurs et à s’attaquer
à du gros gibier il y a 400 000 ans, puis
ils se sont hissés au sommet de la chaîne
alimentaire il y a seulement 100 000 ans,
avec l’essor de l’espèce Sapiens. Mais
la domination humaine relèverait aujourd’hui
de l’oppression, jugent les critiques. Peter
Singer pointe notamment du doigt la manière
dont les hommes réifient les bêtes pour
en faire de simples outils de recherche. Les
chercheurs considèrent « les animaux sur
lesquels portent leurs expériences, écrit-il,
comme des pièces d’équipement, comme des
outils de laboratoire plutôt que comme des
êtres vivants et souffrants » (La libération
animale). C’est à cause de la distinction
radicale de l’humanité et de l’animalité,
estime le philosophe, que l’expérimentation
animale a pu devenir une véritable industrie
dans les pays développés. La domination
de l’homme déterminerait donc sa relation
aux bêtes.
L’iniquité du rapport de force confirmerait
l’idée de l’infériorité animale. Mais
on peut imaginer — cela n’est pas rare
— que la théorie soit venue à la rescousse
des faits. Les êtres humains ont tendance
à essentialiser leurs propres hiérarchies,
à légitimer par le discours la domination
et la soumission. Comment ne pas craindre
que ce mécanisme idéologique ne biaise également
la réflexion sur l’animal ? Lorsque sont
apparus, dans l’Europe du XVIIe siècle,
les premiers automates articulés, on les
compara à des bêtes. Celles-ci ne sont in
fine, comme les machines, raisonnait-on, que
des combinaisons de pièces formant des rouages,
sans conscience ni pensée. Descartes adhère
à cette réduction de l’animal à sa dimension
mécanique. Dans sa Lettre au Marquis de Newcastle,
il explique le comportement animal entièrement
par l’instinct, soit un ensemble de mécanismes
qui s’activent automatiquement en réaction
aux signaux produits par les circonstances.
Il donne l’exemple des chiens et des chats
qui, parce qu’ils ne réfléchissent pas
à leur action, grattent la terre sans finalement
ensevelir leurs excréments. Ainsi, cette
perspective mécaniste apporterait la preuve
de l’infériorité animale.
On peut encore justifier la distinction radicale
de l’humanité et de l’animalité en démontrant
la supériorité de l’être humain. Si les
animaux ne sont que des machines perfectionnées,
le mécanisme ne pourrait en revanche suffire
à expliquer la vie humaine. Un homme doit
donc avoir quelque chose de plus. Seulement,
son corps à lui aussi rappelle le fonctionnement
d’un automate articulé. La preuve de sa
supériorité tiendrait par conséquent à
la spécificité de son esprit. Pour les stoïciens,
par exemple, l’homme a une place privilégiée
dans la nature parce que lui seul possède
une âme rationnelle. Comment l’expliquent-ils
? Dans leur cosmologie, détaille Diogène
Laërce (Exposé général des doctrines stoïciennes),
l’âme du monde est un souffle qui se répand
inégalement dans l’univers pour assurer
la cohésion de la matière. Lorsqu’il est
peu puissant, il crée les êtres inanimés
; lorsqu’il l’est un peu plus, les végétaux
; au troisième degré, il constitue l’âme
des animaux ; au quatrième degré, enfin,
il engendre l’âme rationnelle des hommes.
Cette spécificité rend ceux-ci capables
de vivre selon la perception du bien et du
mal, tandis que les animaux sont, eux, privés
de raison. Telle serait l’origine de la
supériorité humaine.
L’idée de la distinction radicale de l’humanité
et de l’animalité paraît donc de prime
abord confirmée tant par le fait que par
la théorie. À y regarder de plus près,
cependant, cette idée ne mérite peut-être
pas le crédit de l’évidence.
Agissant et pensant avec le préjugé de leur
supériorité sur les bêtes, les humains
ont tendance à nier la part d’animalité
qui les anime.
Ne leur en déplaise, l’animal ressemble
à l’homme en de nombreux points. Pourquoi
l’oublient-ils ? C’est, au moins pour
partie, l’effet du biais de confirmation
: ils ne trouvent que les différences parce
qu’ils cherchent les différences (pour
confirmer leur croyance en leur supériorité)
— qu’ils cherchent donc les points communs,
et la distinction leur apparaîtra probablement
moins radicale. Le corps humain, on l’a
vu, répond également à des automatismes.
L’esprit humain est tout autant susceptible
de conditionnement. Montaigne estime que c’est
la vanité qui rend les hommes aveugles à
ces vérités. S’ils abandonnent leurs préjugés
sur les bêtes et s’ils les observent bien,
ils réaliseront la profonde parenté qui
unit tous les êtres vivants. « Nous vivons,
écrit-il, eux et nous sous un même toit
et respirons un même air : il y a plus ou
moins entre nous une perpétuelle ressemblance
» (Essais). Multipliant les exemples, le
philosophe souligne les propriétés communes
aux animaux et aux hommes : la malice, l’ingéniosité,
la communication, l’anticipation, l’organisation
de la vie collective, ou encore la propension
à aller contre la nature. L’animalité
et l’humanité seraient en réalité inextricables.
Et pour cause, l’homme et l’animal auraient
la même origine. Cette hypothèse contredit
les discours légitimateurs de la supériorité
humaine, lesquels imaginent au contraire des
origines différentes à Sapiens et aux bêtes.
Peut-être les récits mythologiques ou religieux
qui, à l’instar de la Genèse, confèrent
à l’homme un statut exceptionnel parmi
les êtres vivants et une relation privilégiée
avec la divinité dès la création du monde
— peut-être ces récits des origines traduisent-ils
eux aussi le préjugé de la distinction radicale
de l’humanité et de l’animalité. La
perspective évolutionniste, elle, infirme
ce préjugé. Elle révèle que la proximité
de Sapiens avec les autres espèces est, en
raison de la sélection naturelle et de la
lutte pour la vie, bien plus grande qu’on
ne le croit. Darwin explique en effet dans
L’origine des espèces que toutes les espèces
évoluent de la même manière : elles changent
progressivement parce que leurs individus
mutent pour s’adapter à leur milieu. Cette
théorie inscrit l’homme dans l’ensemble
de la dynamique du vivant. Elle l’invite
également à reconnaître, en remontant les
modifications successives de l’évolution,
que son espèce et les espèces animales possèdent
des ancêtres communs.
La radicalité de la distinction entre l’homme
et l’animal serait aussi illusoire à l’échelle
collective. On souligne volontiers que les
Sapiens ont développé une grande capacité
de coopération, ce qui leur permet d’organiser
efficacement leurs communautés. En particulier,
les subtilités de la communication humaine
rendraient possible la compétition pacifique
pour le pouvoir et le consentement des membres
du groupe à l’autorité. La vie politique
des sociétés humaines n’aurait pas d’équivalent
dans le monde animal. Mais est-ce bien certain
? Frans de Waal pense que l’homme n’est
pas le seul « animal politique » (La politique
du chimpanzé). Ayant analysé les dynamiques
sociales des chimpanzés et des bonobos, il
affirme que les racines de la politique sont
plus anciennes que l’humanité. En effet,
il a observé que l’évolution de la hiérarchie
obéit à des lois similaires chez ces hominidés
et chez les Sapiens. L’accession au pouvoir
tient, en dernière instance, à la constitution
de la coalition la plus puissante. Le primatologue
a même retrouvé chez les singes des symboles
politiques prétendument « humains », comme
le fait, pour un individu à la conquête
du pouvoir, de montrer l’importance qu’il
accorde aux membres les plus jeunes du groupe.
Les communautés humaines ressembleraient
donc bien aux communautés animales.
À ce stade de la réflexion, l’idée de
la distinction radicale de l’humanité et
de l’animalité a perdu son crédit initial.
Faut-il pour autant en déduire que l’homme
est un animal comme un autre ?
S’il y a de l’animal en l’homme sans
qu’on ne puisse toutefois les confondre,
c’est peut-être que l’humanité est une
destination, et non pas une propriété innée.
Cette hypothèse est cohérente avec la nature
évolutive de l’être humain. Dans cette
perspective, l’homme serait plus proche
des bêtes dans les premiers stades de son
existence, puis il pourrait s’élever à
la dignité de sa nature dans les stades suivants,
au fur et à mesure qu’il prend conscience
de sa spécificité. Ne compare-t-on pas la
spontanéité de l’enfant à celle de l’animal
? N’associe-t-on pas communément la sagesse
au grand âge ? La noblesse propre à la nature
humaine peut ainsi apparaître comme une conquête
de l’esprit. Rousseau affirme que l’homme
s’est progressivement éloigné de sa condition
animale, « au lieu qu’un animal est, au
bout de quelques mois, ce qu’il sera toute
sa vie, et son espèce, au bout de mille ans,
ce qu’elle était la première année de
ces mille ans » (Discours sur l’origine
de l’inégalité). Pour le philosophe, seul
l’homme possède la perfectibilité, la
faculté qui permet de développer d’autres
facultés. Elle le rend tout particulièrement
capable de s’élever spirituellement en
prenant conscience, d’une part, de sa liberté
de résister aux commandements de la nature,
et d’autre part, de la mort. Il aurait donc
par là le potentiel d’accéder à sa dignité
propre.
Mais l’humanité comme destination serait
plus précisément un projet. S’éloigner
de l’animal jusqu’à s’en distinguer
radicalement, cela ne serait contenu qu’en
puissance dans la nature humaine — rien,
pas même le passage du temps, ne garantirait
que l’homme ne développe sa noblesse propre.
Le dépassement de l’animalité demanderait
un effort : il s’agit de stimuler et d’orienter
la capacité de l’être humain à se perfectionner.
Tel est l’enjeu fondamental de l’éducation,
estime Kant. Contrairement à l’animal,
qui vit exclusivement par l’instinct, l’être
humain peut se perfectionner vers une « destination
» qu’il a choisie. Si la discipline tire
l’enfant de l’animalité, il ne faut pas
pour autant le dresser comme une bête, car
il doit comprendre les principes dont dérivent
ses actions. Le but n’est pas de soumettre
les hommes en devenir, mais de perfectionner
l’espèce humaine dans son ensemble. « C’est
dans le problème de l’éducation, écrit
Kant, que gît le grand secret de la perfection
de la nature humaine » (Réflexions sur l’éducation).
L’éducation est donc la responsabilité
d’une génération à l’égard de la suivante.
Elle signifie que l’être humain peut dépasser
l’animalité en se perfectionnant lui-même,
de sa propre initiative.
Il est enfin possible de transposer cette
idée à l’échelle collective. Peut-être
les communautés humaines pourraient-elles,
elles aussi, évoluer et s’améliorer continûment
jusqu’à ne plus ressembler aux communautés
animales. En quoi surpasseront-elles, ou surpassent-elles
déjà, une horde de loups, ou une tribu de
singes ? Il semble pourtant que les défauts
des communautés animales n’aient pas disparu
des communautés humaines : la rivalité,
l’inégalité, l’injustice, et la violence
ne sont pas des fantômes. Pour Yuval Noah
Harari, la différence fondamentale ne réside
pas là. La distinction radicale entre l’humanité
et l’animalité tiendrait en réalité à
la taille des collectivités. Dans les communautés
d’animaux, avance l’historien, la coopération
se limite à une échelle réduite (les proches
parents, en général), sinon le groupe se
scinde inévitablement en sous-groupes. Chez
les humains, en revanche, la fiction rend
possible la coopération à grande échelle
: « Toute coopération humaine à grande
échelle – qu’il s’agisse d’un État
moderne, d’une Église médiévale, d’une
cité antique ou d’une tribu archaïque
– s’enracine dans des mythes communs qui
n’existent que dans l’imagination collective
» (Sapiens). C’est le langage supérieur
des Sapiens qui leur permet de créer une
« double réalité », grâce à laquelle
ils peuvent se perfectionner collectivement.
L’homme n’aime pas qu’on le confonde
avec l’animal. De fait, il semble se définir
lui-même par son rapport aux bêtes : il
leur serait par essence supérieur. Force
est de constater qu’il les domine depuis
plusieurs centaines de milliers d’années,
ce qui lui paraît conforme à l’infériorité
de la nature animale, comme à l’éminence
de sa nature à lui. Mais l’idée de la
distinction radicale de l’humanité et de
l’animalité mérite-t-elle tout son crédit
? L’homme peut difficilement nier les ressemblances
qui le rapprochent de l’animal, leur probable
commune origine, ou encore la similarité
des logiques qui animent leurs communautés
respectives. Ces éléments attestent certes
qu’il y aurait de l’animalité en l’homme
; cependant, ils n’invalident pas totalement
le présupposé contenu dans l’énoncé.
Et si l’humanité était une destination,
une finalité ? Puisqu’il a la faculté
de se perfectionner, l’être humain pourrait
s’en servir pour s’élever, individuellement
et collectivement, à une dignité supérieure
qui reléguerait vraiment l’animal, mais
aussi l’homme ordinaire, dans l’animalité.